today I'm going to do a reiki and
crystal healing treatment on sharzad and
susan to help balance their energy and
give them some stress relief
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crystal healing is an alternative
medicine practice that has been around
since antiquity with records from
Mesopotamia and ancient China references
as far back as 1700 BC state it was used
in magic healing and protection for some
reason people who use crystals love
talking about how they originated from
the ancients and how they knew so many
secrets about science and medicine I
find that pretty funny considering the
ancients also believed the earth was at
the center of the universe and
bloodletting care diseases the concept
of modern crystal healing is that all
things in the universe have a specific
energetic frequency based on mood or
environment a human being frequency can
be made into positive or negative
frequencies in contrast a crystals
frequency does not change and is very
stable much like a tuning fork there
used to recalibrate our frequency to
make it more stable and positive oh and
by the way these aren't things that I
believe these are things that crystal
healers believe between the aura and the
chakras system which are different
components of our energy field we can
have these imbalances that can create
difficulties and aspects of our life
like mentally emotionally physically or
spiritually during a healing session
crystals are placed on the patient's
body to align with their chakra points
where the crystals place can also depend
on a specific ailment like on the head
due to a migraine or stomach for
indigestion
so what scientific justification do
crystal healers have well let's ask
crystal healing expert teal Swan but
there is more to this physical dimension
and reality than meets the eye our
current definition of what is alive is
incredibly inaccurate the current
definition of what makes something alive
is something that exhibits movement
respiration sensitivity growth
reproduction excretion and nutrition
yeah no this isn't the correct list of
what defines something as living the
correct list is cellular organization
reproduction metabolism homeostasis
heredity responds to stimuli growth and
adaptation but I'm guessing you're going
to disqualify this list because it
doesn't represent all living things we
need to start defining
in terms of consciousness nailed it
what constitutes something being alive
is in fact the ability to be aware to
perceive and to think the ability to
perceive and think are not what
qualifies something as living a
jellyfish can perceive light and sound
but can't think nonetheless it's defined
as living because it executes these
traits to say perception and thought
constitute living is paradoxic as it's
both general and incredibly narrow
viruses and prions are an example of
conscious beings which are very much
alive but which do not exhibit all of
the traditional characteristics that we
think constitute life okay how are
viruses and prions able to perceive and
think with what proof do you have if any
I'll tell you what they really are
though prions are just clusters of
proteins and viruses are nucleic acids
held together in a lipid or protein
compartment no brain or neuro Network
nothing they only spread infectious li
because of their mode of transmission
through food or aerosol particles not
because they're alive also what does any
of this have to do with crystals
minerals especially crystals are also
alive finally here we go
that is they are conscious they are
aware they think and they perceive
if you're going to make the bold
assertion that crystals are living
you've got to provide some kind of
evidence even a sliver is fine we have
discovered life forms deep within the
ocean that are alive conscious and
reproductive whose bodies are made up of
100% silicon their bodies do not contain
any carbon whatsoever wow that's really
interesting no carbon in their bodies at
all it'd be fascinating to see how its
DNA would have no carbon in it despite
carbon literally being an essential
element to form deoxyribose you know as
in deoxyribose nucleic acid or DNA what
I'm going to guess is this woman is
lying or a completely ignorant of
biology the organism she's talking about
are called diatoms and have carbon
distributed throughout its entire body
like every other carbon-based life-form
on earth for example with DNA the DNA
helix only exists with a carbon-based
ribose molecule in it it's true that
silicon is similar to carbon as carbon
has four valence electrons and so does
silicon
however the properties of the silicon
atom are much different from carbon for
example silicon chemistry requires
higher temperatures and carbon to form
bonds and therefore is not conducive to
generate life however there is silicon
in these organisms but it's hydrated
silicon dioxide and is only a component
of the diatoms cell wall that's a far
cry from 100% silicon so where is this
going in relation to crystals well she
is making the connection that there are
organisms made of 100% silicon if they
are living one hundred percent silicon
organisms which there aren't then that
lends the possibility and subsequent
proof that crystals like quartz which is
made of silicon is living which it's not
we have discovered life forms deepest in
the ocean that are alive conscious and
reproductive whose bodies are made up of
100% silicon silicon is the primary
element of quartz crystal crystals are
living beings uh-huh that's analogous to
saying that since humans are
carbon-based life forms and capable of
perception and thought that means my
pencil made of graphite is also capable
of perception and thought and the rest
of the video is just her making
increasingly ridiculous claims such as
these so when you introduce fluoride
into the equation the vibration of that
ailment
the arthritis or cancer must change to
match the vibration of the fluorite when
you have a headache you might take
something like aspirin that's because
there is a component in willow bark
which is what makes up aspirin which
helps the human pain system the
frequency of willow bark is a very high
and slow frequency it's not a compatible
vibration with a vibration of something
like a headache so the frequency of
willow bark and the frequency of
something like a headache are
incompatible so uh let's move on okay
let's apply real science to this firstly
the presence of energy fields crystal
practitioners say both humans and
crystals produce an energy field or Chi
due to a vibrational frequency okay sure
I'll humor you but let's agree on one
thing if there is an energy field that
can be manipulated by a crystal then
logic would follow that this energy
field could also be observed or measured
sure you can't see or measure gravity
with the naked eye however Einstein
mathematically proved its existence with
his theory of general relativity with
the distortion of space-time in contrast
there is no mathematical proof or
explanation of energy fields produced by
crystals because they don't exist the
inability to produce tangible proof of
said energy fields thrust the defense
into an ad hoc fallacy much like Carl
Sagan's dragging in the garage thought
experiment in this famous thought
experiment
Sagan tells an observer that he has a
dragon in his garage the observer
appears inside and says there's no
dragon Sagan then says that the dragon
is invisible then the observer says what
if I use these infrared goggles to see
its heat signal Sagan replies that
dragon is cold-blooded and the goggles
won't work and so on the Crystal
Advocate will make the same endless ad
hoc claims to explain the absence of
something not actually being there for
example many people who are limited by
the physical dimension which have you
believe that you are personifying an
inanimate object when you are treating a
rock like it's a pet or like a person
all right so the energy fields can't be
explained ok maybe the science isn't
there yet but surely crystals themselves
have energy this is obvious because
they're used in lighters radios and
computer chips without crystals
computers wouldn't exist so Kris
also demonstrate the piezoelectric
effect and what this is is basically
when a crystal is compressed or
distorted it allows for the
transformation of mechanical energy
which is that pressure to be conducted
into electromagnetic energy this is why
quartz is used in computers that's why
it's in your phones that's why it's in
radios and this is the connection that's
made it's because it allows this this
energy transformation you can use
crystals to bring you back into
alignment to raise your frequency and
help prevent any sort of disease or
ailment the piezo electric effect
produces electricity and electricity is
energy congratulations on making that
connection but this doesn't validate the
idea that crystals have inherent
spiritual or magical energy that's not
how the effect works when a mechanical
force is applied to a quartz crystal the
crystal generates a brief electric
current this is because the silicon and
oxygen molecular structure is compressed
the average positive charge from the
silicon atoms move upward and the
average negative charge of the oxygen
atoms move downward this displacement of
charges produces a brief electric charge
this doesn't mean crystals are energetic
rather it demonstrates that the atomic
structure of crystals can be altered to
produce a charge also the piezo electric
effect is not observed in all crystals
for the effect to occur the crystal has
to meet two criteria it has to have
polarity and be non centrosymmetric
polarity just means the atoms making up
the crystal don't equally share the
electrons in their bond for example
oxygen unequally shares electrons with
hydrogen non centrosymmetric means the
lattice structure cannot have symmetry
in a quartz crystal the atom directly
across from any silicon atom is oxygen
so it's not symmetric but diamonds do
have symmetry as they're solely made of
carbon and therefore don't exhibit the
piezo electric effect the final
ace-in-the-hole a crystal advocate will
use to prove their point is Marcel Vogel
Marcel Vogel a world-renowned scientist
who holds over 200 patents including one
for the floppy disk discovered that
crystals are able to receive and send
both human thoughts and emotions
Marcel Vogel was a prolific IBM
scientist who held over 32
patents in magnetic and liquid crystal
technology later in his career he
combines science in a cult ISM that led
him to claim some very outlandish
theories about crystals for example he
believed quartz contained a metaphysical
power that allowed them to store
thoughts on one occasion while observing
them under a microscope their crystals
formed into whatever Vogel was thinking
problem with Marcel Vogel as many of his
claims could not be reproduced and had
no legitimate scientific basis just
because a well-known scientist makes her
claim it doesn't mean that the claim is
true because they're really famous
believing what Marcel Vogel said about
crystals is like saying we should study
Newton's work in alchemy because he
discovered calculus in the laws of
gravity when in reality we all know
alchemy is complete bull this brings us
to the real reason why crystals work the
placebo effect the placebo effect is a
beneficial effect on the body produced
by a placebo drug or treatments which
cannot be explained by the properties of
the placebo itself instead the effect
arises from the patient's own state of
mind say you have really bad back pain
your doctor gives you a mint and tells
you it's a really strong pain reliever
you take the mint believing it will stop
your back pain afterwards you sue your
doctor for malpractice but also if you
end up having less back pain that
reduction in pain can not be attributed
to the mints because it was just a mint
instead to your mind and perception
caused you to recognize less pain but
how does this really work dr. Ted
Kaptchuk the director of placebo studies
at Harvard Medical School says that
brain scans show when patients take a
placebo drug believing it will improve
their condition it triggers specific
regions in the brain that release
endorphins and natural painkillers the
same chemical reactions happen when you
experience very positive situations like
receiving your first kiss or getting a
high test score for example when a
patient when a person is treated with
the rituals symbols placebos the pills
whether they have content or not when
you're in pain the brain releases and
doggedness opioids cannabinoids or Pend
or prostaglandins there's a veritable
pharmacy in each and every one of us the
placebo effect is heightened even more
when a patient is in a particular
environment that reinforces the positive
effect
like talking with a healthcare
professional or going to a clinic when a
person feels sick and down and you go
into an environment that's designed to
help you you go into an environment
where everyone around in that
environment wants to help you and
provide you relief and you're in an
environment that these people know every
kind of technology that society has to
make you feel better the brains
processing of sensations self-awareness
and symptom changes sometimes in a very
positive way people who receive the
whole nine yards that is go to a clinic
speak with the healthcare professional
and receive the treatment exhibit the
strongest effects from the placebo in a
study by the British Medical Journal
patients with IBS were treated with
acupuncture and were told the treatment
would reduce their effects 262
participants were split into three
groups Group one was given no treatment
group two was given only acupuncture and
group three was given acupuncture and
spoke with the healthcare professional
as a result 44% of group to notice
inadequate reduction in their symptoms
Group three on the other hand showed a
62% reduction in their symptoms
the increase in relief in group three
was associated with the patient
practitioner relationship now don't get
your hopes up the placebo effect can't
actually cure condition like lowering
cholesterol or reducing the size of
cancerous tumor however it can modify
your perception of symptoms associated
with a condition like bodily pain or
anxiety this is where crystal healing
comes in some people who go to a crystal
healer say they feel positivity or
reduction in symptoms after their
session such as these women who were
skeptical and received a full treatment
there is no scientific evidence that
crystals and gemstones are able to treat
ailments based off their color and
chemical make yeah we both live with
chronic pain and I have a neuropathic
pain called trigeminal neuralgia and I
have enemy trail system mommy
many other pelvic floor dysfunction I've
never tried crystal healing have you I
have not hey hi my name is Juliana Davis
wait oh no I'm a Reiki Master crystal
healer sound feeler spiritual teacher
psychic medium and the owner of aura Lux
they mention how the treatment reduced
their anxiety and stomach problems maybe
it's wishful thinking but it felt like
she was pulling some of my pain out of
my stomach pain where it normally is
it's not as severe right now so I
definitely think there's some sort of
connection between the crystals and the
relaxation that it brought both went to
a clinic were taken care of by a
professional who assured him that the
treatment works and then received the
treatment these conditions are very
similar to group 3 in the IBS study from
the British Medical Journal who had the
highest reduction in symptoms so how do
we know that the placebo effect is at
work during crystal healing British
psychologist Christopher French
addressed this very question in 2001 at
the University of London French wanted
to see whether the placebo effect was
significant in people who believed in
crystal healing 80 participants were
told to meditate for five minutes while
they were holding a crystal the
participants were either given real or
fake quartz crystals but were told they
were all given real crystals prior to
meditation half the participants were
asked if they noticed any effects that
the crystals had on them such as a warm
or tingling sensation in their hand or
positive emotion afterwards all the
participants answered a questionnaire
asking if they noticed any effects from
the crystals results showed that
participants given fake crystals
described the same effects as those who
held real crystals listed effects were
reports of a warm sensation in the hand
holding the crystal and a general
increase of positive mood those who were
questioned before meditation reported
even stronger effects than those who
were not questioned additionally those
who said they believed that crystals had
special powers were twice as likely to
report a facts from the crystals than
those who were skeptical it's no
coincidence that the placebo effect had
a much stronger impact on those who were
previously questioned and held beliefs
in crystal healing it's no surprise
because this correlation is something
scientists call expectancy expectancy is
the patient's anticipation of a future
response after the
administration of a placebo drug or
treatment expectancy is one of the
direct mechanisms that causes the
placebo effect an example would be a
patient who is administered pain from a
shock and is then told they will be
given a topical cream that will reduce
the pain sensation the cream is actually
a placebo
however the variable cues from the
administrator in the clinic setting
causes the patient to have a
preconceived expectation that the cream
will reduce pain expectancy is what
occurred during the Christopher French
experiment and it's what causes people
to receive effects from crystal healing
and other forms of pseudoscience now you
might be thinking well if going to a
crystal healer causes a release of
endorphins and makes the patient feel
better why should you care sure to each
their own however if the placebo effect
works by endorphin release you could
just work out meditate or get extra
sleep to get the same effect instead of
paying losses gemstones all over your
body to aid in the facial process it was
up to frog
but if crystal healing is a mostly
harmless treatment why should we care if
people choose it at all addicted
ignorant is going to talk about some of
the harms of crystal healing take it
away so at this point you might be
thinking that it doesn't really matter
whether people believe in crystal
healing or not after all for most people
crystal healing might mean nothing more
than a collection of pebbles on the
mantelpiece but for some people this
belief goes much further I came across
this case report of a man found dead in
his home with a number of healing
crystals implanted under his skin by
amateur surgery
you'd have to guess it was at least
painful although apparently the crystals
were not the cause of his demise now
cases like this might be rare but the
phenomena of yoni eggs is all over
YouTube and Facebook and quite a number
of women are putting themselves at risk
of infection and I don't think you need
me to tell you where but apart from
these cases of misadventure there are
two main ways that crystal healing harms
its believers the first is financial
sure a chip of quartz isn't going to set
you back much but there are far more
expensive crystals on the market and
there are books and courses that will
set you back hundreds or even thousands
of dollars and if this is money that
people are intending to spend on their
health and well-being it's been sadly
diverted into something
useless and this brings me to my second
point crystal healing distracts from
real treatments yes there are lots of
videos on YouTube and groups on Facebook
dedicated to using crystals for treating
things like migraines back pain
infertility and even cancer and look
when it comes to something as serious as
cancer any amount of distraction delay
and confusion can have real-world
consequences there have been a number of
scientific studies which have found an
association between the use of
alternative medicines in general with
shorter lifespans for cancer patients
and the likely reason for this
association is distraction from
effective treatments like surgery and
missed appointments with real doctors
and the danger of selling ornaments as
medical devices has been picked up
several times by regulators around the
world Gwyneth Paltrow's goop was
recently find a hundred and forty five
thousand dollars for selling a series of
women's health products whose advertised
medical claims were not supported by
competent and reliable science the most
egregious offenders seem to be goups
yoni eggs which the site claimed could
balance hormones regulate menstrual
cycles and increased bladder control in
New Zealand this crystal shop in Napier
was singled out by their Advertising
Standards Authority for its
unsubstantiated claims that its products
provided therapeutic benefits crystal
sanctuary said their products had a
range of health benefits including
protecting against nightmares and
helping people overcome addiction the
claims were found to be unsubstantiated
by evidence and crystal sanctuary was
forced to remove the adverts and in my
native UK the local Advertising
Standards Authority has also rejected
crystal therapy due to a lack of
evidence
in 2013 the a sa considered claims on a
website which implied that crystals
could be used to help heal a number of
health conditions including Alzheimer's
Asperger's a smih depression and heart
disease the advertiser accepted that
they did not hold clinical evidence to
support the claims being made and it was
subsequently ruled that the advert was
misleading the current advice to those
wishing to advertise healing crystals in
the UK as something of a stark warning
because the advertising stands authority
and code of advertising practice have
yet to see any evidence to support
claims the
crystal therapy has a healing effect
marketers are advised that they should
hold rigorous clinical substantiation
before making any efficacy claims about
the therapy despite all this it seems
that crystal healing has infiltrated
conventional cancer care in the UK this
2010 survey found that crystal healing
was used in some hospices and I find
this sad I'm quite confident that we can
offer more to hospice patients than
magic rocks but it's not just the people
who use crystals that this industry
harms crystals sold in shops in the US
and elsewhere are often mined in
lower-income countries in 2019 The
Guardian published an investigation into
the working conditions of crystal miners
in Madagascar find in the child labor
was rampant people were being crushed
and suffocated in collapsing mines and
the unregulated industry threatened the
rainforest and all of this chaos might
be easier to justify of what was being
pulled out of the ground at great human
and environmental expense actually had
medicinal properties now at this point
in the video you might be getting the
impression that we don't like crystals
but that's not true there's nothing
wrong with appreciating the beauty of
nature and all is not lost for those
excited by the potential use of crystals
and geological material more broadly for
medical and scientific purposes sure you
could buy a lump of obsidian from some
cheap website and hope it confers some
kind of psychic ability on you but I
think it's much more interesting to know
that obsidian blades are still used in
surgery today because of their
exceptional cutting abilities similarly
diamond knives are often used for eye
surgery and research into the use of
nano diamonds for cancer treatment is
ongoing crystals are routinely grown in
molecular biology labs the world over in
an effort to understand the structure of
biological molecules in fact the
structure of DNA was only revealed after
DNA crystals were grown in the lab and
this is by no means an exhaustive list
crystals are exciting and they're very
useful but they're just not magical
on the stupid scale I'm reading crystal
healing at a ten out of ten and on the
harmful scale a five out of ten if you
enjoy my series questions pursuit of
science then check out addicted to
ignorant his entire channel is all about
debunking pseudoscience he does an
especially great job at calling out fake
cancer cures and cancer survivors who
promote alternative medicine if you want
to stay up to date on all kinds of
pseudoscience and quackery nonsense I
suggest you check out his channel you'll
be happy you did